i think that people
are always interested in the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
so what do you think would surprise
people to learn about the making of
tomorrow one
it was shot pre-pandemic that might be
something
uh to that would be surprising not only
because of
the moment it's which it's been released
the release had been pushed
uh due to the pandemic but also because
some of the resident
themes that have to do with you know a
global threat and the reliance on
science to face that threat
all of that seems like it was sort of
born in the imagination of the
experience
of kovid but it was actually done before
kovitz so that's just
a bit of coincidence i i would say we
we all got along a lot better than most
people think actors get along
on set i mean if that's if that's
something that i don't know we uh we had
a great time
filming this this movie um it was it was
epic and um
yeah i don't i don't know man uh like
there's a lot of
random weird things that that happened
on set but i think our uh
our connection was it was a little
profound it was cool
i'm definitely curious when you guys
first saw jk simmons on set for the
first time
were you like why are we even this movie
because he could just kill all the
aliens on his own
yeah yeah he's pretty jacked very jazzy
i found out that jay and jk
stands for jack jack yeah i i hope i
look that good
dude at his age yeah that's that was it
was pretty ridiculous like you could see
all of his veins like his muscles were
bigger than mine
and i thought i had big muscles at the
time um yeah he's a thoroughbred yeah
he's ripped he's fantastic one of the
things i really enjoyed about this movie
is you guys pulled the bad boys too
i thought the movie was ending and but
that was just the end of the second act
there's a whole other chapter that's
going to have the bad boys too the bad
boys too
i i call up the bad boys too because
when i first saw that
it you know it has a whole nother
section yeah yeah yeah
can you sort of talk about the fact that
this doesn't follow like there's some
surprises in this movie
it makes you want a journey yeah yeah it
really does it's an unconventional
structure and it's a lot of storytelling
for two hours you know
we're we're talking about three very
distinct
chapters obviously you don't want to
lead with that because it's a bit of a
we hope we hope that that's we just want
we just want people to get on board once
you're on board once you're in
for this ride it'll take you a ride it's
it's different than what you might
expect
and uh our goal is really just to get
people
seated down in front of it because we
i'm really confident in the story i
think it's really great i think it's
really moves
i think it's a non-stop ride and
it's hard to it's hard to talk on the
the
peculiarity of this structure without
giving things away so i know what you're
saying but also
i'm i'm ready to expound too much
yeah i didn't i'm not saying anything
specifically i'm just saying that
there's a lot to this movie
um yeah what is the secret to fighting
aliens that are not actually
there with you acting it's acting yeah
it starts
i mean it starts in the mind you know
it's it's it's
you know being that that five-year-old
kid with that imaginary
friend you know how do you put yourself
in this world and how are you going to
interact with this world um
and not only are you doing it but you
got to do it with you know
three four five six other actors on your
side
you know um and and collectively
we all just have to be on board what
what is
what is this this moment what are we
doing here
and once we've all defined it for
ourselves
you know then we're able to go in and
and you know make the process easy but
it starts in the mind you know and i
think that's where actors
kind of spend 90 of our lives just
in our heads you know always creating
and recreating
yeah and tech there's a you know certain
technical recipe
for these types of things uh obviously
you can't
you you're dealing with empty space
sometimes
so to like react to that it can be
complicated like
you said we act or you keep it in your
mind and that is true and also
the emotion really plays in close-ups so
when you're in close-ups you can put
something real that an actor is looking
at so you can
you can draw emotion from a real threat
they have either the
three-dimensional uh sort of like foam
dummy version of the white spike where
we have this brilliant performer named
troy
who's like seven feet tall and if you
can get past the fact that he's wearing
gray spandex you get right into the idea
that he's a
monster and it could lift you up and rip
you in half quite easily so
all the fear and the emotion all of that
stuff is played
in in in the tight close-ups against you
know in in those you're allowed to
play opposite something and draw from
something real i i'm very curious chris
this is your first time being an
executive producer on a film of this
scale
what did you learn making this that you
hope to put in other
you know what did you learn that you
hope to bring with you to future
projects
the separations and the preparation it's
all about
setting yourself up for success in the
day that you shoot i've learned that
you write one movie you shoot another
movie
and you edit another movie so you know
the goal post is constantly moving
and you're you're tailoring the film
that you
have sometimes away from the film that
you intended just because of what
happened in the middle
um i'm it's a collaboration uh
and and there are a plethora
of choices that need to be made and the
secret sauce
when it's six and one half dozen in the
other and
is to be is to have conviction in your
choice
when you're not even sure the right
answer choose one with conviction
and everyone will fall in line and say
well no he said six it's six and one i
know
because look how convicted he is in that
belief so it's just like
choose move go forward and um you know
and take it don't get try to see the
forest through the trees but don't
forget it's just tree by tree
yeah uh before i run out of time with
you guys i'm excited both of you have
upcoming projects that i'm really
excited
about um edwin i'm very very excited for
this lakers project
and i'm curious if you could talk a
little bit about that and chris
obviously the you guys just wrapped
recently on the jurassic world movie
the third installment uh what how was
that shoot and what can you tease people
about the story and
you know making that film you first i'll
go first uh so yeah i'm uh working on
the showtime
lakers project and um it
it is it is about uh you know the
premier
um lakers period where where they
actually changed the game
you know the mid mid 70s into the 80s
magic kareem
cooper nixon um you know
this this team really
made basketball what it is today yeah
bus and west and just um
it's it's it's an amazing story that's
all i can really really say
i can tell you that the actors are
phenomenal
i can tell you that what i've seen looks
absolutely amazing
and that the lakers fans will indeed
enjoy it
so yeah and for me
jurassic three it's um
it's an epic it's a film of epic
proportions
it's got the entire legacy cast
uh sam neil jeff goldblum laura dern um
bd wong they all come back and so it's
sort of like avengers
infinity war of the jurassic world
you know like all the characters are
converging into one
massive epic global story that
is it's just everything you could
hope for and more yeah i cannot wait uh
on that note
uh uh congrats on the movie hope it's a
huge hit for you guys
thank you thank you so much thank you
appreciate it